jean très stylée les français ne savent
pas je ne pensais jamais de ma vie faire
de la plongée autonomie vous pouvez me
souhaiter bon courage
à très bientôt sur arte france
[Musique]
est ce que vous répondez quand on vous
soupçonne et on soupçonne votre
industrie d'être sulfureuse d'industrie
elle est extrêmement contrôlée croit
puisque reverse 50 5 % de notre chiffre
d'affaires à l'état et à la commune qui
sont donc très intéressé au fait que le
fonctionnement soit clean
on fait exactement comme les banques les
compagnies d'assurances est ce qu il ya
de l'argent suspect nous sommes dans
l'obligation de le déclarer comment se
répartit 100 euros de mise globalement
aux machines à sou par exemple moi j'ai
dans l'obligation de vendre en moyenne
85% que nous on n'a absolument aucun
intérêt à ce que quelqu'un aille
raconter qu'il s'est ruinée au casino
passé repas pouvait dépenser des sommes
extrêmement importantes allant jusqu'aux
millions d'euros aujourd'hui ça n'existe
et on est beaucoup plus dans le loisir
aujourd'hui ce qui fait notre marge
c'est la fréquentation et le nom
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
et ne pas sanitaire pourrait bien être
validé cette semaine le texte est
actuellement entre les mains du conseil
constitutionnel qui devrait se prononcer
jeudi sur la question
l samedi près de deux cent mille
personnes selon le ministère de
l'intérieur ont manifesté dans toute la
france pour répondre aux plus sceptiques
emmanuel macron invite les français à
lui poser des questions directement sur
les réseaux sociaux plus de quarantaine
pour les voyageurs en provenance des
états unis et de l'union européenne qui
voudraient se rendre au royaume uni les
restrictions restent en revanche en
place pour les français un long rêve
auquel la prime variant bêta dans
l'hexagone le gouvernement français
n'apprécient pas forcément cette
décision
[Musique]
israël les états unis mais aussi la
grande-bretagne accusent l'iran d'être à
l'origine de l'attaqué d'un pétrolier en
mer dom and hell téhéran dément
fermement ces allégations et parle d'une
riposte à tout aventurisme jeudi dernier
pétrolier géré par un milliardaire is
règne a été la cible d'un drone d'après
l armée américaine l'attak a fait deux
morts parmi l'équipage
[Musique]
bonsoir à toutes et à tous et bienvenue
si vous nous rejoignez sur rt france
avant de développer ces titres un point
sur la situation sanitaire en france
situation décrite par olivier ferrand
comme fragile et incertaine dans un
entretien accordé à ouest france ce
week-end le variant dalta progresse
aujourd'hui
1137 malades sont actuellement en soins
intensifs elle 22 % des lits de
réanimation sont occupés par des
patients atteints du coc u19 elle
certaines régions sont plus touchées que
d'autres notamment l'occitanie avec un
taux d'incidence en hausse à 41 % sur
une semaine validera ou ne validera pas
l'extension du passani terre c'est la
question que va se poser cette semaine
le conseil constitutionnel elle est sage
comme on les appelle comme on appelle
ses membres du ce rendent doivent rendre
leurs conclusions jeudi si le texte est
validé même partiellement il sera alors
appliquée à partir du 9 août
est ce week-end sur le territoire plus
de deux cent mille personnes selon le
ministère de l'intérieur ont défilé dans
la rue une mobilisation en hausse
en plein été qui inquiète l'exécutif les
vaccins arn messagers distribué par
pfizer et moderna seront désormais plus
cher à l'achat pour l'union européenne
est la faute aux variants delta qui et
nécessitera d'adapter à les produits à
la nouvelle menace à voyait justement
les précisions de lucas léger vacciner
vacciner vaccinés depuis des semaines
médecins et personnalités publiques
politiques se bousculent sur les
plateaux de télévision pour marteler
cette injonction qui pourra peut-être
nous permettre de sortir de la crise du
coc vite 19 seulement voilà les vaccins
ils ont un coût sur rfi le secrétaire
d'état aux affaires européennes clément
boon a confirmé une information diffusée
par le final celle times selon laquelle
les vaccins pfizer et modern a avait
augmenté leurs prix dans le cadre d'un
accord avec l'union européenne
selon lui ce prix s'explique par
l'adaptation des vaccins aux variants et
aux conditions de production et de
livraison imposés au laboratoire
il faut regarder tout cela de manière
rationnelle ne pas se faire avoir
évidemment mais avoir des contrats plus
exigeants avec des produits adaptés aux
variants probablement
oui mais pas seulement pour l'union
européenne pour tous les acheteurs
ce sera un peu plus cher pour le
sécrétaire d'état l'europe qui achète de
très gros volumes de vaccin permet de
payer moins cher la dose que si c'était
les états eux-mêmes qu'il le faisait
selon les informations du financial
times le vaccin files heures devrait
passer de 15 points 5 euros à 19,5 euros
et celui de modern à 2 19 euros à 21,5
euros
les vaccins devraient être gratuits lors
les transactions à leur sujet de votre
transparente et les brevets devraient
être publics
ils sont au service de l'humanité et
l'humanité ne doit pas être au service
des spéculations financières aux des
gros laboratoires pourquoi est ce qu'il
n'ya pas de vacances en france depuis 20
mois
pourquoi est ce que nos chercheurs
depuis 2009 qui avait déjà touché au
coronavirus n'ont pas été aidés pourquoi
être le gouvernement n'a pas mis des
milliards en plus pour la recherche par
quatre moments l'absence de fred public
dans ses derniers résultats trimestriels
la seule société pfizer a annoncé un
chiffre d'affaires de 18,9 milliards de
dollars sur l'ensemble de ses activités
et prévoit pour 2021 33,5 milliards de
dollars de chiffre d'affaires sur ses
ventes de vaccins développés avec bio
ntech bien plus ce que ce qui était
espéré par la société en mai et puisque
la crise semble s'éterniser que la
vaccination générale est présenté par
les autorités comme la seule réponse
crédible pour endiguer l'épidémie
certains font désormais remarquer que ça
commence à coûter cher n'est justement
pas dans cette augmentation des prix des
vaccins avec gilbert collard député
européen identité démocratie
ah bon soir gilbert collard merci d'être
avec nous ce soir sur arte france alors
qu'ils avaient vus comme nous faison et
moderna qui augmentent leurs prix auprès
de l'union européenne
qu'est ce que ça vous inspire tout
simplement que des pierres cette belle
humanité des vaccins il y a une énorme
affaire d'argent avec des
démultiplicateur financier aux
ramifications toujours inconnue au
moment où le président de la république
en tee-shirt noir propose de répondre à
toutes les questions qu'on pourrait se
poser sur les vaccins on apprend que
weiser va faire quand même de sacrés
bénéfices puisque l'augmentation qu'ils
organisent correspond à 25%
d'augmentation ce qui est quand même
quand l'érable les contrats ne sont pas
lisibles
on ne les connaît pas et on a le
ministre des affaires européennes qu'il
dit qu'il faut que désormais on soit
plus exigeants en ce qui concerne les
contrats ce qui veut dire qu'on n'a pas
été jusqu'à présent il faut savoir lire
ce qui est écrit
il faut savoir entendre ce qui est dit
on a des contrats qu'on ne connaît pas
il y aurait des clauses
d'irresponsabilité il y aurait des
clauses de désengagement en cas d'échec
des traitements on n'arrive pas à
vérifier ses 10 partout mais à ce jour
on n'a pas encore accès à ces documents
il y avait que rennes doctrinal qui sont
terribles sur la réalité de ces vaccins
et on voit que c'est quand même une
affaire d'argent
de gros sous alors c'est vrai que ya
fort longtemps qu' on aurait dû avoir
les contraint il ya fort longtemps que
les brevets devraient être d'utilité
publique des désengager de tout
actions financières commerciales parce
que là où il ya l'argent il ya forcément
le vice
on le sait de toute histoire du
capitalisme ça c'est pas c'est pas
nouveau bon et on n'a pas les prudences
nécessaires face à cette marche reste
vous intervient quelques secondes vous
avez été nombreux dans la classe
politique ces dernières heures a dénoncé
l'augmentation des prix des vaccins mais
est ce qu'on connaît vrai elle
réellement le prix d'un vaccin
non non la pax au contrat moi je les
connais pas le tout ce qu'on sait c'est
qu'il ya une augmentation qui est enfin
on passe de 15 euros à 19 euros
voilà donc ces files heures qui nous le
dit donc on avec l'augmentation qui est
de l'ordre de 25% et on passe pour
modern à 2 19 euros à sauf erreur de ma
part toujours possible 21 euros 50
et l'argument qui est donnée repris de
chefa isr c'est que ce coup
s'expliquerait par la nécessité de
s'adapter aux variants alors que avant
même qu'il eut les variants files heures
avait annoncé qu'il serait probablement
obligés d'augmenter alors on a une
augmentation du prix des doses et on a
la possibilité sur le fondement des
variants de plusieurs doses non pas deux
mais trois non pas trois mais peut-être
quatre tarbes ont donc on est dans une
situation où on est en plus piégés parce
que files heures en france il est dans
une situation absolument de monopole de
de domination donc on est quand même
quelque part complètement piégée est on
est on n'a rien fait pour être
indépendant de
du fil et financier du filet que l'union
européenne veut absolument cacher ses
contrats avec avec les labos
pharmaceutiques à moi je le pense est
vraiment ce qui me
ce qui m'intrigue beaucoup c'est le
propos du ministre des affaires
européennes sauf erreur peint par quand
il dirige des contrats plus exigeants ça
veut dire quoi
ça veut dire que dans les contrats ne
l'ont pas été et puis pourquoi on les
voit pas ses contrats pourquoi ils ne
sont pas mis à la disposition des
citoyens
pourquoi on ne on n'est pas un fort
parce que vous comprenez il ya le fait
que ces contrats procure des bénéfices
aux laboratoires qui dans l'économique
habite m normal mais il y à toutes les
ramifications tous les tous les lobbys
qui travaille à la consommation de ces
vaccins ils les mecs qui sont en lien et
on ne le sait peut-être pas du reste il
ya tout cela qui est quand même très
préoccupant dans un moment où les
vaccins sont quasiment rendu obligatoire
si c'est pas une affaire de quatre sous
on a vous avez indiquée les bénéfices
pour être fait 33 5 milliards de chiffre
d'affaires 33,5 milliards de chiffre
d'affaires pour fighter merci quand même
mais impressionnant
merci gilbert collard d'avoir été avec
nous ce soir sur arte france
elle rappelle que vous êtes a débuté
européen identité et démocratie merci
beaucoup
l'accès au pass sanitaire facilité pour
les expatriés français au ru e c'est le
cas aux états unis où ceux qui le
veulent pourront convertir leur carte de
vaccination locale en qr codes en
perspective d'un voyage en france
en revanche aucune avancée pour les
expatriés ont reçu un vaccin non
reconnus par l'union européenne elles
sont concernés notamment à les vaccins
russes et les vaccins chinois
on en parle justement avec notre
correspondant à washington tom abonnés
un thomas bonsoir alors comment ça se
passe exactement pour obtenir ce fameux
qr code afin d'être en mesure de se
plier aux pas salutaire et donc de
pouvoir rentrer en france cet été pour
les expatriés
c'était un peu un angle mort finalement
de cette mise en place du pass sanitaire
en france quid à des milliers de
français expatriés qui se sont fait
vacciner dans leur pays de résidence et
qui n'ont donc pas ce fameux qr code
alors une procédure vient d'être mise en
place
ce lundi il faut remplir un formulaire
indiqué un certain nombre de documents
et tout cela il faut l'envoyer à une
adresse mail qui a été créé
géographiquement donc par région une
pour les états unis pour la côte est par
exemple et je peux vous dire que ça
répond à de nombreuses attentes voire
même des inquiétudes de grand nombre
d'expatriés qui sont ici aux états unis
on peut voir notamment sur ces fameux
groupes facebook des expatriés français
qui vivent aux etats-unis beaucoup
d'inquiétude pour ceux qui voulaient se
rendre en france cet été et qui donc ne
pouvait pas être en mesure d'obtenir ce
qrcode alors on verra maintenant comment
cela va se mettre en place concrètement
puisque une fois que ce mail a été
envoyé il faut ensuite attendre la
réponse à des autorités compétentes on
n'a pas encore de délai sur la d les
soldes sur la livraison de ce fameux qr
codes on peut aussi dire que c'est un
petit peu tardif puisque ce pass
sanitaire est déjà en déjà il déjà ce
pas sanitaire en france pour un certain
nombre d'activités donc pour ceux qui se
sont rendus en france cet été ça peut
déjà être compliqué pour eux on rappelle
aussi qu'il est toujours des
restrictions de voyage quand même pour
les français notamment qui vivent aux
états unis puisqu'ils peuvent faire le
voyage en direction de l'union
européenne mais c'est bien plus
compliqué pour faire le voyage inverse
puisque je vous le rappelle est
frontières américaines sont toujours
fermées aux voyages non essentiels en
provenance de l'union européenne et puis
il ya surtout donc un gros bémol
eh bien ce sont les français qui se sont
fait vacciner avec des vaccins qui ne
sont pas homologués par l'union
européenne on pense par exemple aux
vaccins russe aux vaccins chinois alors
pour eux il est possible qu'une autre
d'injection soit nécessaire une
injection avec un vaccin homologué par
l'union européenne écouter est ce qu'en
dit le secrétaire d'état chargé du
tourisme jean baptiste lemoyne dans le
jdd
pour les vaccins non homologués par l'
agence européenne nous avons demandé aux
experts scientifiques d'évaluer à
quelles conditions il pourrait être
complété par une vaccination avec la rn
messager en france le président de la
république a par ailleurs souhaité que
soit déployé une campagne vaccinale à
destination de nos compatriotes établis
dans des pays où l'accès au vaccin est
encore compliqué il ya évidemment
beaucoup d'inquiétude pour ces français
qui sont concernés ils ne savent pas
encore vraiment s'il ya une
compatibilité entre les vaccins qu'ils
ont déjà reçu et puis cette fameuse
troisième injection qui serait peut-être
nécessaire pour eux et puis quand aux
doses qui pourrait être délivrée est
acheminée en direction des français qui
n'ont pas accès aux vaccins on rappelle
que c'est une promesse qui avait déjà
été faite au mois de mars dernier
puisque le secrétaire d'état chargé du
tourisme expliqué à l'époque que 16% à
des expatriés français dans le monde
n'avaient pas accès au vaccin alors
certains attendent toujours et il y en a
même qui ont dû bénéficier du service
kovacs pour pouvoir se faire injecter
des doses de vaccin si thomas abonnés
pour toutes ces précisions thomas
bonneau notre correspondant à washington
les français j'ai même vacciné seront
toujours obligé de subir une quarantaine
s'ils veulent entrer au royaume uni est
ce n'est plus le cas depuis ce matin
pour les voyageurs en provenance des
états unis et des autres pays de l'union
européenne est les britanniques évoquera
notamment la présence du variant bêta
dans l'hexagone une situation que le
gouvernement français n'apprécie pas
vraiment les précisions de françois
xavier lambert
invariants bêta potentiellement plus
résistants aux vaccins et qui pourrait
se combiner aux variants delta voici la
crainte qui a conduit le gouvernement
britannique à maintenir une quarantaine
pour les voyageurs français arrivant
royaume uni une restriction qui concerne
même les personnes complètement vaccinés
pour de nombreux français vivant dans le
pays cette décision est incompréhensible
la 40e est une bonne idée pour les gens
qui ne sont pas vaccinés mais si on est
vacciné il devrait pas avoir de
quarantaine et je suis pour les tests
pour faire attention mais pas plus c'est
un peu difficile puisqu'elle beaucoup de
personnes qui font le trajet si assez
régulièrement donc sa cause à ces
problèmes mais je pense que c'est un
mode de faux classé nécessaire pour
garder la sécurité des français et des
anglais en maintenant pour justifier sa
décision le gouvernement britannique se
base sur une initiative scientifique
appelée j side celle-ci collecte et
fournit depuis 2008 des données
génomiques sur certains virus dont le co
vide
selon des chiffres cumulés depuis
plusieurs mois il y aurait 5,2 pour cent
de variants bêta en france contre 0,1
pour cent au royaume uni et 1 4% en
espagne
mais cette interprétation est dénoncée
par le gouvernement français qui avance
en autres chiffres le mois dernier
seulement 1,9 pour cent des séquençages
du coc vie de réaliser dans l'hexagone
correspondait aux variants bêta c'est
une décision discriminatoire à l'égard
des français puisque tous les européens
même des pays qui ont des situations
sanitaires plus difficile que la nôtre
au titre du variant d'état ou autres ne
sont plus concernés par cette
quarantaine les précautions britannique
sont notamment liés à la vague
impressionnante du variant delta
laquelle le pays a été confronté le
royaume uni peut pourtant compter sur le
succès de sa campagne de vaccination le
pays affiche une couverture vaccinale
plus élevée que celle des pays de
l'union européenne
neuf adultes britanniques sur dix ont
reçu au moins une douze et sept sur dix
sont complètement vaccinés
le nombre de cas quotidiens à d'ailleurs
commencé a dit
et on repassant sous la barre des trente
mille j'ai remarqué que de toute
évidence les chiffres s'améliorent
depuis six jours mais il est très très
important que nous ne nous permettrons
pas de tirer des conclusions prématurées
à ce sujet étape 4 de la levée des
restrictions n'a eu lieu qu'il ya
quelques jours les gens doivent rester
très prudent et cela reste la proche du
gouvernement cette quarantaine imposée
aux voyageurs français arrivant royaume
uni pourrait cependant ne pas durer très
longtemps
l'ambassade britannique en france
annonce une réévaluation de la situation
dès la semaine prochaine
est il possible levée de la mesure et
royaume uni qui joue la guerre de la
prudence c'est ce que nous explique paul
thompson vice-président du parti
conservateur britannique en france a
selon lui sa décision de lever les
restrictions pour certains pays et pas
d'autre n'a rien à d'arbitraire n'aura
mené était très mandement touché le
premier ministre lui même a été
hospitalisé sa situation était assez
grave pendant quelques jours donc il ya
une grande sensibilisation aux dangers
que représente la pandémie cependant
vous l'avez dit le taux de vaccination
complète ce même au dessous de 70 %
aujourd'hui et le nombre de nouvelles
infections est en baisse et il se
trouvait un niveau relativement
relativement bas et on considère aussi
que le en plus delà du nombre de
personnes vaccinées il ya une autre
facteur qui contribue à l'immunité
collective à savoir juste le nombre de
personnes qui ont déjà été infectées
dont il ya une logique scientifique
derrière cette cette politique et donc
elle n'a rien d'arbitraire ou 2010
réfléchi
olive ans maintenant deux jours avant la
première commémoration des explosions du
port de beyrouth c'est les familles des
victimes sont toujours en quête de
justice
la déflagration a fait 214 morts et plus
de 6500 blessé un an plus tard et malgré
les promesses des autorités
aucune enquête n'a abouti sur les causes
de l'explosion a selon amnesty
international les ingérences de la
classe politique libanaise freine
l'enquète et empêche les familles de
faire leur deuil
en attendant elle est libanais assure
toujours trop maquillée l'explosion vit
toujours en moi et ça va rester comme ça
pour tout le reste de ma vie
nous nous rapprochons du 4 août tant que
personne n'a été arrêté ou envoyer en
prison
la colère montera de plus en plus fort
ça nous donne envie de tout casser de
descendre dans la rue et de manifester
de jeter des cocktails molotov sur le
gouvernement de déclencher en feu
c'est une colère interne permanente
cette période déclenché beaucoup de rage
et de désespoir
c'est parce que nous avons pensé qu
après l'explosion la classe dirigeante
n'avait aucune chance de rester au
pouvoir
ça semblait impossible après un
événement pareil c'est littéralement
leur incompétence leur négligence et
leur corruption qui a fait sauter la
ville et nous y voici un an après rien
n'a changé c'est juste absurde
rien n'est logique l'asb chalet elouges
ce qui a suivi l'explosion a été une
perte d'illusions pour tout le monde moi
y compris
nous attendions a tellement de la part
de ce pays au liban nous nous sommes
toujours vanté de pouvoir nous amuser de
pouvoir vivre heureux c'est comme si
tout cela s'était brisée israël les
états unis et la grande bretagne
accusent l'iran d'avoir été l'auteur
d'une attaque d'un pétrolier dans la
main
dauman jeudi téhéran rejette en bloc ces
accusations et parle de riposte à tout
aventurisme amaya soubelet téhéran nie
toute implication
mais israël maintient ses accusations
après l'attaqué jeudi en mer d'oman d'un
pétrolier géré par un milliardaire
israélien
l'état hébreu a annoncé ce dimanche
détenir des preuves de l'implication de
l'iran tel aviv appelle la communauté
internationale à prendre des sanctions
contre le pays tout en le menaçant de
représailles sur masterchef sigran de
hoffen par d'année j'ai maintenant
entendu que l'iran d'une manière lâche
essaie d'échapper à sa responsabilité
dans cet événement il le nie j'affirme
donc ici de manière absolue c'est l'iran
qui a mené l attaque contre le navire le
comportement agressif de l'iran est
dangereux non seulement pour israël mais
aussi pour les intérêts mondiaux la
liberté de navigation et le commerce
international les preuves en matière de
renseignement existe et nous attendons
du système international qu'ils fassent
comprendre au régime iranien qu'il a
commis une grave erreur
en tout état de cause nous savons
comment transmettre le message à l'iran
à notre manière rolnik les murs des
navires est à merano l' attaque de type
drones selon l'armée américaine a causé
la mort de deux personnes et n'a pas été
revendiqué directement mis en cause par
israël téhéran demande au gouvernement
de naftali bennet de cesser de lancer
des accusations infondées
il ces déclarations sont définitivement
condamné le régime d'occupation de
jérusalem doit savoir que ces
projections ne résoudront pas ces
problèmes
quiconque tente de frapper un coup fera
face à un plus grand coup la république
islamique d'iran n'hésite pas un instant
à protéger des intérêts suprêmes du
peuple et sa propre sécurité nationale
et rodez mois en faisant pourquoi outre
israël le royaume uni a également accusé
l'iran d'être à l'origine de cette
attaque tout en prenant quelques
précautions dans sa déclaration
nous pensons que cette attaque était
délibérée ciblées et une violation
flagrante du droit international par
l'iran les évaluations britanniques ont
conclu qu'il est très probable que
l'iran ait attaqué le mv moeurs en
stricte dans les eaux internationales au
large d'oman le 29 juillet en utilisant
un ou plusieurs véhicules aériens sans
pilote
une prise de position partagée par
washington ce dimanche les états unis
ont même promis à téhéran une réplique
appropriée
un épisode de tensions qui intervient
alors que les discussions sur le
nucléaire à vienne semble bloquée
jusqu'à l'entrée en fonction du nouveau
gouvernement iranien en afghanistan
maintenant l'étau se resserre autour des
grandes villes dans le sud du pays les
forces afghanes à se mobilisent pour
empêcher les talibans de mettre la main
sur une première capitale provinciale
la sga regard les détails avec six et
bourrés la pression des talibans
s'intensifie en afghanistan dans la nuit
de dimanche à lundi ils les combats se
sont amplifiées entre les forces
gouvernementales et les insurgés
une capitale provinciale lashkar gah
mais aussi quand d'art et et ratent deux
grandes villes du pays pourrait tomber
prochainement
les ambassades américaine et britannique
basée dans la capitale afghane accuse
des talibans de massacre
ce lundi elle appelle au cessez le feu
immédiat à spin boldak dans la province
de kandahar
les talibans ont massacré des dizaines
de civils par vengeance
ces meurtres pourraient constituer des
crimes de guerre ils doivent faire
l'objet d'une enquête et les combattons
commandant taliban responsables doivent
rendre des comptes
le royaume-uni et les etats-unis
appel au cessez le feu immédiat dans un
discours au parlement
le président afghan achraf rani pointe
du doigt le retrait rapide des troupes
américaines
ils jugent washington responsable de l'
escalade de violence dans son pays
c'est à ce même la situation à laquelle
nous sommes confrontés est due à cette
décision soudaine
j'ai dit au président américain que je
la respectais car c'était sa décision
mais je savais que cette décision aurait
des conséquences et que la gestion de la
crise incomberait aux afghans à new
delhi ap des apprenants nos paroles ou à
chelsea
chaque ce processus de paix a créé le
doute et l'ambiguïté et son résultat et
la situation que nous voyons
actuellement je veux répéter ici que
notre priorité dans les lignes de la
république est une paix durable
mais malheureusement je vois que les
talibans et leurs partisans veulent
l'insurrection
l'avancée des talibans et la hausse des
violences contre le peuple afghan a fait
réagir washington l'administration biden
a annoncé élargir le champ des afghans
pouvant bénéficier du statut de réfugié
aux états unis une décision qui pourrait
permettre à des milliers de familles de
s'installer de manière permanente sur le
sol américain
mais le département d'état américain n'a
pour l'instant donné aucun chiffre
précis sur le nombre de personnes
pouvant bénéficier de ce programme
voilà c'est la fin de ce journal merci à
vous d'avoir suivi prochain point sur
l'actualité est dans un peu plus de
trente minutes rester avec nous sur arte
france
c'est à la vie
[Musique]
la raison pour laquelle les gens qui
font appel à moi s'engage dans un combat
c'est parce que il ya de l'autre côté
une classe ultra privilégiés qui